a disgrace to his uniform serial rapist
David Carrick is also another alarm Bell
but police vetting has failed
the Prime Minister met with the Met
commissioner who revealed this week that
more than a thousand of his officers
remain in service despite allegations of
sexual or domestic abuse now the home
office wants all police forces to check
their own against National Police
databases I've just had a constructive
meeting with the commissioner of the
Metropolitan Police and made clear to
him and he agrees that the abuse of
power that we've seen this week is
absolutely despicable and it needs to be
addressed immediately
the problem no doubt extends Beyond
London speaking out for the first time a
retired police officer we're calling
Sally who we can't identify says she
reported her ex-husband for rape he was
also a serving officer in the north of
England who worked on sexual abuse cases
but Sally says officers handling his
case had been his colleagues or Old
Friends
he let me tell him everything that
happened from start to finish and then
at the end of it said right let me tell
you that you know I grew up with him and
how did that make you feel
damage had been done by then then the
detective Sergeant who was leading the
investigation she told me that my
partner had worked for her as well which
shocked me
Sally learned her ex-partner was also
alleged to have been violent to his new
wife and separately a neighbor had
raised the alarm well sadly shown us
this letter that was sent by a neighbor
complaining about the same man but this
time with a different wife and it says
the arguments are getting worse it
sounds as though it's turning physical
the worrying thing is he works for the
police and I thought he'd know better
and he ends by saying I feel for the
woman's safety
I just don't feel believed I feel like
it's all been brushed under the carpet
charges were eventually dropped against
Sally's husband and he kept his job
until retirement
during the investigation which was nine
months I drink up every month asking for
an update and apparently I was needy
because I was always on the phone
wanting to know what was happening
if it happened to me again I wouldn't
report it I found the investigation was
more traumatic than the actual incident
it is the story of David Carrick that
has prompted Sally to speak out do you
think that the police service is
institutionally sexist
no I don't
but the chief of police inspectors has
called for Swift action as we know it's
not the first issue in relation to
officers who have committed serious
offenses and not just in the
metropolitan police either this is a
nationwide issue
so that culture that culture that is
pervasive in some parts of policing
needs to be rooted out
Sally says the police needs to take
complaints against its own officers more
seriously
do you think it would have been handled
differently if he wasn't a police
officer I do yeah I do and that is the
big concern that the police has a blind
spot for its own bad apples Jason
Farrell Sky News